so we were talking about the hound now I
wonder if I had her three choices again
for her hit list you think she's picked
the same people who just actually pick
this is a thing at the beginning of
season 3
Gendry was giving her a hard time about
the people that she chose but I think at
the time she kind of didn't really I
didn't really believe that this guy
could do it so she was like okay the
tickler you know I mean this guy was you
know not really a great person and could
do without him so yeah and she wears oh
yeah this is this is kind of cool and
then this is a memory launch afterwards
and that's because she really needs to
save her ass I think and she was kind of
in trouble so yeah but I think you know
at that time it was just the first one
was just like Oh what esta and then she
got herself into trouble so she had to
kind of kill those people quickly and
then she escaped Harrenhal which is
quite clever I think but yeah I think
you know if he hadn't got herself into
that mess she would have chosen Joffrey
and Cersei and limb pain I don't know in
what order she would choose definitely
Ilyn Payne I think because he seems like
a bit of a psychopath and Joffrey and
Cersei oh I don't know I guess if you
took one of them away it'd be kind of
different for the other I'm not sure I
think Jeff I think I think so see
without Joffrey that that would be okay
so if if we kill Joffrey that'd be good
and we're talking about Harrenhal right
so that makes me think obviously of
Tywin Lannister you were his cup Bearer
how fun was it tricking Tywin yeah I
think it's great I really loved the
scenes when I first read them and then I
wasn't over like oh god I'm gonna be
working with Charles dance you know and
I think that I think you know I would
just think he's a nobody and you know
there's something a little bit different
about her but I don't think he really
suspects that she's Robb Stark's younger
sister because you know she would have
been a lot more trouble then but yeah I
think she's just kind of cruising under
the radar and then Littlefinger comes
along and that kind of you know she gets
a bit
yeah give me a bit aware that you know
she was kind of confident in Harrenhal
one bit like oh you know I can I can
deal with this and then kind of spun it
on this head a bit so then she was a bit
like oh god you know don't get too
comfortable there's still people out
there that kind of want to get you so
yeah it was kind of a different a
different thing that I was kind of come
across really she's usually just trying
to convince people that she's boy and
now she's actually gotta convince people
that she's not herself you know and it's
um yeah it was very different to sort of
have that other aspect to it I think and
um I got on really really well with
Charles dance and yeah the scenes were
fantastically written and um it's just
nice to be a part of that really yeah
they were brilliant scene so I know
they're on the book but they're superb
scenes I'm glad they were in the TV show
we actually spoke to Charles Dancy other
day and he is singing your praises very
very highly and rightly too but we asked
him whether he thought giving enough
time that Tywin would have realized that
she was I a stark and he said yes he
would've done definitely what do you
think I think he's kind of wise and
eventually he would have worked out but
I think Arya was sort of quietly
confident that she would be gone by then
and she didn't plan on staying there
after the rest of her life so yeah I
think she kind of played her cards right
then maybe he he would have just been oh
okay you know you're doing all right you
can go what something yeah I think he
possibly would have recognized a given
more time so it's good job girls there
instead because he could be dead right
now you've always liked working with
girls done so what did you learn from
working with people like Charles and
Sean being as well Michelle Furley it
sounds weird it's kind of like the
ability to just incorporate props
it's just sounds I'm wrong but it does
make a complete difference like how
natural is and especially with the
language on Game of Thrones it's not you
don't feel like you'd naturally say that
and you know saying father and mother
and it's like I'm just like that's my
mum my dad you know perhaps so it's kind
of you know the language the stuff makes
it feel a lot less natural anyway and
then to incorporate your props and just
be able to relax on camera then makes it
feel a lot more believable I think and
especially in the
world which is kind of like a fantasy
world so you don't you know there's not
much realism I guess so it's you know
that that is kind of an element that
I've learned from a lot of actors to
kind of make it look more natural and
feel more natural and yeah that's
importantly think I want to ask you
about Melisandre because she said that
she sees darkness in you didn't she
what do you think about that um I think
that's kind of a bit of a wake-up call
to Arya and um she's already heard these
people like um
Valar cimbalom on coulis and Valar
dohaeris and I think she realizes all
there's more to this world than I
originally thought
and um and now Melisandre is coming out
with these things and she kind of was
just like Oh everything she says rubbish
and tries not to believe it but then you
know when she's really saying something
to you and saying you know I shall shut
forever it's kind of like oh yeah and um
it could just be all rubbish but still
it does make you think and um yeah it
was an intense scene as well like a
Graham Chris grab my chin and like I
couldn't see and if the camera or
anything were just like looking into
each other's eyes and I was like oh it's
kind of gave me chills a little bit and
it was um yeah it's kind of scary and
she died didn't blink as well and that
was kind of odd like I was like when
you're gonna blink and there's some
times I was there and I was like when is
she gonna blink back into the sea yeah
but it was I remember reading it and
being a black this is this is a new
thing to Arya and yeah it's kind of
chilling I think
you